[Música]
Sofía empamar Muchas gracias por
compartir este momento con nosotros en
Franz 24 Gracias letter tu segundo álbum
Tiene 18 temas 18 palabras en inglés que
leídas verticalmente forman la frase
querido público tu amor me salvó de la
soledad para siempre sinceramente sofián
Posdata escribí este álbum en Asia
actualmente estás de Gira Mundial Cómo
sientes esta conexión con el público así
la conexión
Pues esa es la conexión que dio un giro
a mi vida de antes cuando tocaba solo
con mi piano hasta el momento en que de
repente todo adquirió un significado y
un alcance nuevos desde el momento en
que realmente conocí a este público y el
público empezó a enviarme emociones de
vuelta y que no era yo solo el que
enviaba emociones A través de mi música
Y así fue como este diálogo empezó a
cambiar mi vida por completo primero
ocurrió con mucha fuerza en Europa y en
mi país Francia y ahora la escala
completamente loca con esta gira aquí en
América Latina en abril estoy de gira en
Estados Unidos y cada vez tenemos más
lugares también está Asia que está
tomando buen rumbo lo que es una locura
es que hice este disco para agradecer a
mi público y el público me lo sigue
devolviendo cada vez más y más
doblando
esta frase que caracteriza tu segundo
álbum tiene más resonancia hoy que te
presentas ante todos estos públicos que
nunca antes habías visto
sin duda lo que estás diciendo Ahora va
a ser real para el resto de mi vida creo
Cuanto más suba más sentido tendrá esta
frase y por eso estoy tan contento de
haber escrito en mí de momento pequeña
discografía con dos discos esta frase
porque creo que va a envejecer muy bien
si sigue así el pasado noviembre te
convertiste en el primer pianista
solista de la historia en llenar el
emblemático ver si de París que se llama
ahora Accord hotel arena una sala de 20
mil asientos símbolo de éxito en Francia
háblenos de aquella velada
fue una completa locura hubo muchas
cosas que fueron una locura esa noche el
hecho de ser el primero de la historia
en una sala que representa algo tan
importante en Francia ya era un honor y
algo completamente loco para mí luego
desde el momento en que llegué
evidentemente los preparativos fueron un
gran debate Porque queríamos que fuera
espectacular yo adapto mi espectáculo a
los distintos lugares aquí estamos en un
teatro no voy a tocar de la misma manera
que en un estadio como inversi es muy
diferente Así que pensé mi espectáculo
de forma completamente diferente pero
sin dejar de orquestar todo en torno al
piano y el
citamos y donde tuve más emoción Por
supuesto fue el día de cuando empezó hay
instantes en los que casi perdí el
conocimiento porque la emoción era
demasiado grande es son momentos con los
que he soñado desde que era un niño
viendo artistas que me inspiraron a
levantarme y ahora que está sucediendo
en el momento en que estaba así de mí me
sentía abrumada el escenario estaba en
el centro y hay un momento en el que
entro y están todas las luces del
público encendidas Cuando miré todas las
luces a mi alrededor es cuando casi me
desmayé
en medio de un concierto en medio de un
concierto casi me desconecto del todo
Simplemente porque era demasiado era
demasiada emoción incluso ahora hablando
de ello todavía me dan escalofríos
te llaman el piano
un título que tú también utilizas para
describirte Pero dices que es porque hay
que autoproclamarse hasta que funcione
ser artista es ante todo un gran trabajo
mental
Ah sí Y creo que esto se aplica a todas
las disciplinas los deportistas lo saben
muy bien Ahora estoy muy cerca de
grandes deportistas que escuchar mi
música y no reconocemos en el proceso
creo que desde el momento en que quieres
lograr algo que requiere esfuerzos casi
sobrehumanos significa que tienes que
tener una mente fuerte y la mejor manera
de tener una mente férrea es trabajar en
ella y este autoproclamado rey del piano
es una forma de pensar que cuando lo
digo tengo que estar a la altura del
título que me doy a mí mismo también hay
un lado Soñador veo el mundo como
unánime como un manga como un territorio
de Aventuras un poco imaginarias Así que
lo que hago es muy concreto Pero me
gusta verlo de una forma poética y un
poco más imaginativa
y luego jugar a querer llegar a ser el
mejor la provocación cosas que siempre
han hecho los artistas de rap y hip hop
el rap y El hip hop son mundos en los
que también evolucionas siempre has
querido mezclar estilos y códigos de
música moda y actitud que van con ellos
Sí porque representa mi experiencia mi
enfoque de la música y de la vida es un
poco tópico decirlo pero cuando escuchas
rap te comportas de una determinada
manera tienes un determinado estilo de
vida que es más mi estilo de vida en la
forma de provocar en la forma de
vestirse en la forma de pensar Pero yo
no soy rapero soy pianista y nunca he
visto ningún problema en comportarme así
en la vida y tener otra disciplina que
es el piano
de hecho creo que Cuanto más cómodo te
sientes con lo que Define tu identidad
más lo sientes más lo compartes y así en
esencia me encontré rompiendo muchos
códigos Simplemente porque eso es lo que
soy
y hablando de inspiración y de
latinoamérica tienes dos temas Medellín
y la Habana que marcan ese vínculo con
el continente y ahora está girada por
aquí tienes algún artista en mente con
el que te gustaría colaborar
persona que te Inspire que venga de
latinoamérica
creo mucho en las cosas que suceden de
forma natural Así que si esto sigue así
aquí en Latinoamérica sé que
naturalmente conectaré con artistas de
aquí y estoy deseando que llegue en este
momento escucho mucho a Chucho Valdés El
pianista cubano y cuando pase un tiempo
en Cuba así compuse la Habana y cuando
fui a Medellín así compuse la canción
del mismo nombre pero en aquella época
ni siquiera había publicado mi primera
álbum Así que estaba en mi viaje de
inspiración viajando por el mundo para
descubrir cosas y encontrar estímulos
emocionales para crear nuevas canciones
sea Give y era más noble y ahora la
historia es que me encuentro volviendo a
estos lugares para tocar todas mis
canciones pero especialmente las
canciones de estas ciudades obviamente
cuando estoy en la ciudad donde compuse
la música y vuelvo allí como artista
para actuar cuando toco esa canción
siento muchas cosas
nos hablaste de tu amor por el rap pero
hubo otros estilos y Obras que te
impresionaron mientras crecías y
aprendías música estoy pensando quizás
en la música de cine
mucho he hablado mucho en entrevistas de
la música del padrino porque fue la que
me marcó de niño y luego es curioso
Cuando eres niño te apegas mucho a
ciertos temas que luego se convierten en
tus temas recurrentes y eso me pasó de
niño la relación con el cine y con las
grandes películas es algo que ha
permanecido y que además me inspira
mucho por ejemplo me han dicho aquí que
esta película se llama perfume de mujer
o en español perfume y mujer y en
francés se llama letham weeken
creo que es una película preciosa es una
película que me ha inspirado mucho y
podría citar con joaquin Phoenix que es
una historia de amor increíble lo que me
gusta del cine es que estés donde estés
en el mundo puedes sentir emociones muy
muy grandes y transformarlas en algo ya
sea para mí con el piano que sea para
otros con el dibujo la pintura o
simplemente sintiendo cosas así que sí
el cine es algo esencial para mí
los animales
subían en las entrevistas hablas a
menudo de tu madre y de tu abuelo es el
que vemos en el videoclip decían que yo
era solo un músico
si es mi abuelo waste al que perdí muy
pronto pero los pocos años que pasé con
él me bastaron para recibir su energía
para siempre es una persona que me ha
marcado enormemente además de su
historia además de ser el que más
sacrificio hizo por la familia siendo
minero del Carbón en el norte de Francia
él era un bereber del Marruecos llegó a
Francia para trabajar en las minas que
es un trabajo sacrificado que nadie
quiere hacer es un trabajo que haces por
amor a tu familia y entonces este amor
Yo trato de honrarlo Así que mi madre
dio el primer paso al ser la hija de
este hombre extraordinario y luego yo a
mi vez intento hacer lo mismo con mi
hermano y mi hermana también estoy muy
unido a mis hermanos a mi padre somos
muy muy familia saca a ver si
completamos
y cada uno con sus habilidades intenta
conseguir algo grande podías elegir lo
que quisieras pero lo importante era
llegar muy lejos en eso ese era el
contrato que teníamos en casa Y creo que
esta relación es algo que reproduciremos
y que me parece hermoso y universal por
dónde voy encuentro esto los valores de
la familia son cosas que me conmueven
enormemente porque creo que es quizás el
valor más universal que he encontrado en
el hombre es el hecho de amar de
sacrificarse por los demás y de
construir como una comunidad con los
suyos
Y tu hermana es la única artista con la
que has colaborado en tu último disco
ella y tu hermano iniciaron en la música
Gracias a ti la transmisión es algo
importante para ti
es que la transmisión
lo que pasó fue que empecé a tocar el
piano mi madre me puso a tocar el piano
porque me regaló un pianito de juguete
yo ya tenía muy bueno oído de bebé
Entonces se dio cuenta de que me atraía
me metió en el conservatorio y vio un
documental que decía que el piano es el
rey de los instrumentos Así que quiso lo
mejor para mí y por eso me proclamé rey
del piano En referencia a este
documental
y mujer y
tu mundo y en relación con mi hermano y
mi hermana es que claro ella puso música
a todo el mundo porque a mí me iba bien
y así se convirtió en nuestro lenguaje
en el que nuestros padres sienten pero
no hablan así nos convertimos en una
hermandad de músicos hijos de no músicos
y luego Lina y Adam cada uno siguió su
camino pero mantuvieron la música en sus
vidas adames ingeniero de Inteligencia
artificial y líneas diplomática Así que
Lina es la única invitada en mi segundo
álbum
y ella vino a ver sí
Ella vino a ver si y allí fue el gran
momento emotivo para toda mi familia su
momento favorito creo que el público
sintió algo muy fuerte porque recibí
muchos comentarios sobre esta actuación
tuve el honor de tener muchos amigos muy
famosos que participaron en mi concierto
pero Lina sin ser conocida porque su
trabajo es ser diplomática es increíble
como brilló en verse Y cómo hizo que la
gente sintiera tantas emociones pero
creo que también se trata de lo que
representamos como hermanos y hermanas
creo que son las dos cosas La Música Y
esto y sí eso me hace sentir muy muy
orgulloso
he visto
muchas gracias Gracias a ustedes por su
confianza sigan con nosotros hay más
cultura en francés veinticuatro punto
com
[Música]